[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sehr liebt
dienstag vor der tür am 14
für alle die vergessen haben und
vielleicht möchte er gerne euren
liebsten oder eure liebste mit einem
leckeren frühstück überraschen
ich habe heute zehn ideen für euch
verbrachte und flüsse und ich denke dass
ich euch ein paar instructor und geben
kann also start mehr gleich idee nummer
eins ist aber auch tomaten pfeil
dafür braucht ihr dazu formaten etwa
käse und einem farbstoff ab die daten
werden jetzt halbiert und war diagonal
dann wird die eine hälfte gedreht
so entsteht das herz mit einem beifahrer
gesetzlich und auf dem käse schneidet
noch die pfeilspitzen zurecht
[Musik]
doch
die rosmarin kartoffeln in herzform darf
euch bereits ein paar kartoffeln
geschält und scheine dies ein zentimeter
dick zurecht
und bekennt heck ausbrechen aus stecken
und die reste können somit mit backofen
oder ihr könnt die weit kochen und
kartoffelpüree verarbeiten oder auch
anderer verlassen
da komme ich mit dem olivenöl drang dann
wirklich viel mit der das eis treffer
und rosmarin und da kommen sie in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad für
etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
bitteschön gold frauen werden
[Musik]
nummer drei für die kleinen kunden von t
zur verfügung gesicht für den pantic
braucht ihr ein eines verbrechens zu
kamel einem teelöffel backpulver
stammend und fünfte vom joghurt so
erklingen und berühre das mit dem
puderzucker und einer vielzahl richtig
schön sauber
[Musik]
nun
es kommt die milch und der joghurt ab
und dann vermisse ich mit backpulver und
würde im totalen ganz locker ein
[Musik]
den hype passionierter ist mit einem
einfarbigen ganz kleinen und kleines
heimweg zu machen und so habe ich immer
die genau gleiche menge dem kardinal
pfanne die habe ich bereits mit ba2
gefährdet und wagt einen blick auf
wasser
[Musik]
die pendler jetzt noch hübsch dekoriert
dafür nimmt etwas den tellerrand blicken
erwärmt hier ein paar zucker münder und
ein paar pico hätten
[Musik]
die flugaufsicht etappen die werden auf
einem ganz einfachen perfekt zubereitet
für den hefeteig braucht er zwei
esslöffel warmes partner einen halben
würfel hefe wirklich vom weißen oder vdk
ein eigentlich mit den liter milch
enthalten fehler 250 gramm mehl und
wirklich kaum nach
zuerst einmal fröhlich jetzt gerät mit
dem warmen wasser
da kommt der zucker meter zu
in eine rührschüssel ihr könnt ihn zeit
vom sommer hin und verkneten
da kommst du hier schon wieder 2
im weg
unter fettleibigkeit in vier bis fünf
minuten weiß lebens und geht ganz
einfach mit rein
[Musik]
und wenn der teig zu viel von mir
einfach ein bisschen mehr fotos ein
reifer aber durch heiligen schrift
[Musik]
na
hilfreich dürfte jetzt eine halbe stunde
aufgehen vielmehr gibt auf der bemehlten
arbeitsfläche etwa 5 mm dünn aufräumen
mit herzen ausstechen und dann
frittieren
[Musik]
zum auftanken können die sammlung öl
frittiert oder für kokosöl nehmen und
das styling einem holzstäbchen hinein
haltet und kleine blume blessing
hinaufsteigen für tolle der bei
mittlerer hitze erhalten und die hessen
werden auf den beiden seiten goldbraun
aufgewachsen
[Musik]
die herzklappen perfekt und sobald sie
aufgegangen sind dreht wieso bekommen
sie eine wunderschöne form
[Musik]
nein
nummer fünf ist auf diese spiele live
dafür nämlich zwei eier trennen
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier bereits eine
pfanne erwärmt damit etwas butterschmalz
und lege trifft auf löcher rein einmal
ein herz ein kleines und ein größerer
kreis in das herbstliche das eigelb ein
und lasst uns erst kurz stoppen und das
geht am schnellsten wenn ich mal einen
deckel aufgebe und verwaltung am rand
leicht stock kommt das eiweiß auch
mitgezogen
[Musik]
fakt ist dass peter trost hierbei habe
ich das gut für mich aufgebrochen dann
beliebig belegt ich nehme produkt und
gäbe und das ganze central ist an ihm
kommt aktuell getestet
[Musik]
die
nein
[Musik]
idee nummer sieben ist ihr herz war mit
der butter waffe nämlich einen
katzenfutter block und halte ihn und
stellte ihn dann mit herz aus bechern
aus
[Musik]
ganz einfach zu nehmen wir einfach käse
und wurst bleiben und meine frau oder
schlecht sie hat damit aus
[Musik]
nummer neun ist der milchsektor
verliebte und zwar habe ich dafür 250
milliliter milch eine banane und eine
handvoll frauen erfährt in einem mit
vergeben und zu einem krieg bearbeitung
und die letzte idee ist bei cappuccino
oder latte macchiato zum beispiel dafür
habe ich einfach hingenommen in der
mitte gefaltet und bietet dann eine
schablone genommen und über gestreut
[Musik]
blicken
vogel
[Musik]
das frisst ich fertig und ich sind
wirklich wunderschön und ich denke für
jeden bereich ist etwas dabei auf den 5
sie haben aber die wenigsten angst warum
also viel lieber zum klang als er ist es
wirklich liebe oder hass zu fall kam
der cappuccino ist mit liebe gemacht
wirklich noch viel ausrechnen
man kann an ob salat machen mit herbst
vor allem im spiegel nicht oder
jedenfalls wieder gefallen hat
vielleicht führt er uns dann eure
rezeptideen eure valentinstag für stück
- einfach auf instagram oder auf
facebook und auf die vernehmung
angegeben
ja kein problem aber ich denke ja dass
du mir ist dann am valentinstag
zubereitet und soll deswegen habe ich
das wirklich auch die anleitung kann ich
dann für mich zu bereiten nein alles gut
also viel spaß machen und wir sehen uns
dann linken wartet dann mit einem
anderen video cd trägt einen
herzschrittmacher oder hapag vor
[Musik]